business strategy kind of thing where
it's like you're you're honing into your
specific niche
but i just don't want to do that because
that's
not loving iphones and ipad is just like
like two percent of who i am
[Music]
hello all and welcome to mooco's corner
mooco's corner is a show about leading a
life that feels more you in both your
life and tech career i'm your host
mayuko and invite you to come in sit
down get cozy and enjoy the show
so today on the show we have yuka oishi
yuka is a digital creator based in
brooklyn new york she shares tech
reviews productivity tips and creative
tutorials on youtube she loves to talk
about everything apple camera gear and
bts so
we've talked about bts before i'm not
really a bts fan but i learned a lot
from you yes
we can talk about that all day but
well i'll we'll kind of like i'll kind
of learn a little i feel like i learned
a little bit more and more about bts
army
so we'll kind of get into that as well
but how's your week been so far it's
monday so it's the beginning
yeah um
good so
i have we were just talking before the
show that i am moving out of this
current apartment in a month
um
a little less than a month now
so we've been apartment hunting
fiercely for the past week or so and
so that's kind of like what was on my
mind for the past week yeah is it really
competitive in new york to find a place
to rent
um i think it's like at least for
brooklyn because it's so
big and there's so many apartments i
mean there are a lot of people too but i
think it's a little bit
easier than maybe san francisco oh
really that's good i think so yeah i
always had the impression that like new
york was as competitive or more
competitive than san francisco but san
francisco's like seven miles across or
something like that it's so tiny and i
mean i guess manhattan is too but
brooklyn's across yeah brooklyn's bigger
and then if you want to live in a
certain neighborhood that's also like a
little bit like it's pretty big
and in san francisco there's you know
like building laws that don't allow you
to like build past
like four
stories or whatever in some areas so i
think there's like definitely like a
housing shortage that makes uh in
certain areas if you really want to live
in that neighborhood or whatever right
um so i think there's less of that here
yeah and there's good transportation in
new york too yeah
live in surrounding areas no problem
yeah
whereas like the bay it's like if you
live in oakland good luck with the bart
like
yeah
and i don't drive so
um
wow new york is perfect for you new york
is perfect yeah well on the show today i
have a few topics lined up about kind of
like creativity freelance i'm also being
bilingual because a lot of your content
is also it's like in mostly japanese
these days yeah i know you used to make
english content and stuff as well but we
can kind of see where the time takes us
so actually you and i know each other
through
the internet right i think
we met so
initially instagram no we were both on
um rebuild which is a japanese tech
podcast
and i think we met that way or something
i think i reached out and i was just
like i'm gonna be on rebuild and i saw
you were on it hi yeah
i think yeah we
kind of like noticed each other through
that and yeah talking like dming each
other yeah yeah we probably only hung
out like
three times or something like that yeah
because we used to live in the bay area
together we went to vidcon together and
stuff so most of our interaction has
been online
that's true i mean for those of you who
don't know yuki's content like i feel i
really admire your stuff because it's so
like creative focused and it's very just
like
every time i watch a vlog i'm just like
man i want to get to like yuka's level
and like photography and editing yeah
also all of your like recent stuff of
just like your um career series too has
such good animations and everything and
i was like oh i feel like i asked you
earlier and i was just like where do you
find your animations like how do you do
these colors and how do you do all that
you're just like i just google it and
i'm like
where are you looking because i can't
find them
we talked pretty regularly and uh the
most recent one i think we talked about
kind of like our mission and youtube and
stuff like that and like you you said
that your mission is to kind of like
empower people to be creative and and
like live a creative life i forget the
exact wording but it's like to be
creative right and so kind of like i
think a lot of our listeners and viewers
of course they often like ask me about
this like how do you foster creativity
like how do you become a creative person
i think also because like my backgrounds
and like the sciences and stuff it's
just like there's this so like
juxtaposition of you're either technical
or sciencey or you're creative so how do
you think about your creative process
like walk us through that what are you
thinking about what are you feeling one
thing that it reminds me of is so i used
to work at pinterest for
five years
and pinterest mission was really similar
they also changed their mission
statement through throughout the years
but basically
we wanted people to use pinterest to
like get new ideas and try new things
and get inspired and then like not just
consume those ideas but just like go out
and do those things and just put it in
action and that's something that i
really
liked and really felt passionate about
while working at pinterest and one of
the things that we talked about when we
were going through that like mission
statement is like why do people feel
like they're not creative
as an adult i think a lot of people if
you're not
a
like
an art school grad or if you're not a
designer
a lot of people would say they're not a
creative person
but
i don't think that's true and uh it
doesn't you don't have to have a
creative like creative labeled career or
education to be creative i actually
don't have that either so i
even at pinterest i was like a program
manager and wasn't doing like design or
anything or anything related to video
at all but i was able to just learn for
myself
basically like 99 percent of the things
i've learned is through youtube just
google whatever i need to and and
learned
most of the things is like teachable and
like learnable by yourself but i think
it's just that mindset of people
thinking that it's not
possible for them or they're not
artistic enough or creative enough to
just get started or like try it out
yeah wait okay can i ask you a little
bit more about your time at pinterest
because i don't think we've actually
really super dove deep into this before
but like what was it like working at
pinterest like now that you're talking
about like it's a lot about like
fostering creativity as a company like
were there a lot of creative types there
like how
how like silicon valley
like san francisco tech startup was it
like what was it like
um i think compared to other
silicon valley companies it was probably
like the culture was probably a little
bit more
creative and like artistic
than maybe some other like very very
tech focused um companies uh so like one
of the values that we had at the time is
like called knit
it's like knitting but oh
it means to
uh it's kind of like related to you know
content on pinterest like knitting is
like a huge topic but also about
intervening different parts of the
company different functions
and really weaving those in to make
something great so it's like about
collaboration and i really like that
word because it's it just like kind of
really
has a good meaning and
really represents the culture that it
that pinterest had at the time
so cool yeah so i think was a company
has a value called knit
right
i think i like from what i've heard from
other companies
maybe some companies are like very very
design driven
and like designers at the top of the the
hierarchy or like
uh engineers are like treated like god
and they get to do whatever they want
yeah but i feel like pinterest had a
pretty good
balance between
all the different functions and everyone
was pretty nice we had like a really
nice culture everyone's uh really
like collaborative and
sometimes like that could lead to like
decisions not happening fast enough or
whatever but i think that was like a
good culture culture fit for me at least
that makes sense i kind of get why you
and i
like fit so well because like patreon
was also a much more creative company
than the typical like software engineer
like silicon valley startup
um but at the end of the day it's still
technology and so like it had this kind
of like under
layer of creativity like music in the
arts and just like creation but then at
the end of the day like a lot of us were
there executing and like building stuff
and like serving creative communities
and now we're both like full-time
content creators we bring a lot of what
we learn from back then into our current
work definitely yeah do you think you
would have become a content creator if
you hadn't worked at pinterest like now
that i'm hearing about how you're able
to foster your creativity at pinterest
like it's i think it's interesting
sometimes like the companies that you
work at become like a part of you and
your identity and your work ethic like
do you think that was that had a huge
impact
i think so but even before joining
pinterest i was really passionate about
like
creative or like internet
platforms that allowed
people to make a living off of it so
you know like way back when it was like
maybe youtube was kind of like one of
the first platforms that allowed uh
youtubers to be like
like make
make being a youtuber their jobs um and
then there came like instagram or other
like tiktok is now like a really popular
platform but you know even pinterest
sends a lot of traffic to blogs or like
different other different um
domains or
other people's platforms and that
really
allows them to have enough traffic or
revenue through through pinterest so
it's kind of
maybe not necessarily like original
content uh hosted on pinterest but it's
like a part of the ecosystem that allows
creators to make a living on the
internet so that's actually one of the
things i talked about in my like
interview when i was interviewing for
pinterest like that's one of the things
that i wanted to
see more of in the world
because that's it just like opens up so
many different opportunities for
different people with different passions
so i've always been kind of passionate
about
supporting people like that and now i
feel like i just became one myself yeah
like this was like written in the stars
from like a long time ago that you were
gonna do what you do now maybe yeah now
that i think about it
yeah i feel like stuff like that you
know it's like you there's all these
like little things that lead up to
like what
ends up becoming i guess i saw um i read
a post on instagram this morning from a
comic artist that i follow called mari
andrew
and i think like the qu she wrote a post
about this phrase called ripe fruit
falls quickly and she and i've never
heard of that phrase before but it's all
just about kind of like when fruit is
ripe like it it falls really quickly and
so that kind of like equates to like
life where it's like when there's like a
ripe opportunity it comes quickly or it
explains like
if there's like something that you're
really into or interested in it happens
really quickly i'm just like you're just
gonna like go from a to b and finish it
or you meet a friend and you're just
like i've never met you before but all
of a sudden we're best friends because
this relationship was very ripe
and she went on to talk about how like a
lot of things in life we don't expect
that things are happening like that
fruit is growing that things are
flowering that fruit is ripening but
when it is ripe it falls quick and then
we notice that things are going on and i
feel like that's such like a like a
creative's
like mentality of just like
like even if it doesn't feel like you're
outputting something or you're not being
productive or whatever like you just
have to trust that things are happening
and like that's what makes it kind of
scary a little bit because you have to
trust in the unknown but i thought that
was a really lovely thing that i i read
this that's a really
pretty way of
phrasing it i feel like yeah
maybe sometimes it's called a sign like
you could call it a sign that like
things happen quicker
or
i guess like maybe different cultures
have different ways of saying it but i
definitely like i feel like we've
both like had moments in our lives where
it's like why why is this happening so
quickly like like it's kind of scary
when that happens right oh for sure yeah
i mean you made a video recently about
freelancing and like becoming a
freelance content creator and like you
interviewed me and the this other person
uh named horikuti-san for it um it was
all in japanese so can you kind of like
recap that video for us a little bit
yeah so
whenever i like do you know amas on like
instagram stories or whatever
a lot of people ask me about um
freelancing and
uh like what i did to prepare or what
it's like i think a lot of people are
curious about
how freelancing works or just how to get
clients or whatever so i just wanted to
make a
video and it ended up being like 30
minutes long because like the interview
i did with you and what do you say was
like so good i didn't like really want
to cut anything out
so it became super long but i think it
was really helpful for people who are
like kind of looking into that space
and we answered questions like like what
did you do
to prepare yourself to become freelance
or what type of people are
like good for freelancing
and like what did you learn uh in
through working at companies before
becoming freelance
right because all three of us had worked
at like tech companies exactly yeah
right i thought i actually didn't know
that about horizon i was watching it i
was just like whoa like this is a
pattern like maybe
those of us who work in tech are
probably or maybe like the most
positioned in some ways to become
creative types sometimes
yeah and then like even within tech we
all had different like functions because
he was in sales
at yahoo japan
um so probably not maybe not as
technical but he
has had been like blogging for so many
years right taking photos and stuff on
his own what i think is also so cool
about what you do is like you talk a lot
about creativity but and oftentimes you
talk about it in japanese so it's in
this kind of like japanese creator
economy japanese creatives like space
but you also talk about it in terms of
just like like last year when a lot of
stuff happened for the asian american
community
um you talked about that you also like
translate stuff that's happening in
america too japanese yeah like here's
what's happening with black lives matter
and stuff and i love this kind of like
cross-cultural
knitting if you will
what you do with your content and stuff
so like and i think that's also one of
the reasons why you and i connect so
well of just like we share similar
background of like being japanese and
like growing up in america right and so
like i don't know like how do you like
one topic that i often think about and
talk about on my channel in other places
is like like how do you weave all of
that together and i don't know if that's
something you consciously think about or
not but like how do you
think about that in your own life in
your own work yeah so
i think if i only did like if my channel
and all of my social media was only
about like iphones and ipads i think i
would have more followers or like i i
would grow so much faster because it's
just like business strategy kind of
thing where it's like you're you're
honing into your specific niche right
but i just don't want to do that because
that's
not
like
loving iphones and ipad is just like
maybe like two percent of who i am
and maybe some people know me be like or
like notice me because of my iphone
review content or whatever because it's
it's just like it gets more views than
maybe other topics
but
i don't
that's just not like the whole picture
and i do want to grow my channels and
everything but i also
want to show
who i am and kind of like
be able to talk about different topics
through
my lens because if i don't if i omit
that lens and like my point of view then
people should just go to like the verge
to get like
gadget reviews because what is the point
of coming to me
if you only want like
facts and specs you know right that's so
true
so
for me i just want to weave in like my
experiences my point of view
how i
live
and like
everything that i am interested in so
like for example bts has nothing to do
with tech
but sometimes it does because like i got
to review like bts like phone cases and
airplane cases
sometimes it comes together sometimes it
knits perfectly sometimes it doesn't
it's fine
but i feel like um just showing up as
myself it's just like what i enjoy and i
think some people may like that some
people may just want tech content but i
just want to be me
i feel you there yeah i often think
about that for my channel too where i'm
just like i could just make
coding content tutorial content but like
there's so many other great channels out
there already that i think would will do
a much better job than me really
truthfully what would i even bring to
the table and it's not like making that
content is like valuable but is it like
what i really want to do like not really
like i want to talk about stuff that i'm
interested in so like whatever that
might be you know i talk about
stationery a lot and that's like the
complete opposite of technology it's
like pens and pencils like
old school stuff
but it's so exciting too right i mean
maybe it's because they're japanese
i can't not use a pencil and pen and
paper and stuff for things
but like i feel like it's so satisfying
when you find your people who like like
all of that i don't know like you
probably have fans who are just like i
love bts and i love apple products and i
love notion tours and i love creativity
and then they find you and they're just
like
but yeah i've become like internet
friends with like
like my viewers because they would like
send me their
uh like bts crazy like insane notion
databases about bts and she was like
here's what i did and i was like oh my
god you are
killing it
and then i actually showcased it in my
one of my videos oh that's so nice she
made her happy i think yeah i bet she
was like i feel so seen right now
she said like she started a notion
because of one of my videos but she just
like went and like
did her own thing and it was
i could never get on that level
your notion videos are so good i
recently made an ocean video too and i
watched yours because i was like
how she did it because you're like
multiple videos and they're so in-depth
and i'm just like all right i got i
guess get some inspo like what features
do i want to cover so yeah i definitely
lost yours oh thank you there's so many
features right there's so many features
yeah i think like i think i
you released some of those notion videos
even before i started using notion oh
really yeah because i was like kind of
anti-notion for a little bit because i
was like
like it's not the easiest to use i think
obviously i was stuck on like the every
new line is a new paragraph formatting
and i was kind of annoyed about that but
then i realized every paragraph can move
as it's its own block yeah and i use
like tables and databases and that's
when i was like
right and so i remember watching yours
and honestly like i've introduced it to
like a lot of other friends when they're
japanese i'm like watch this video it's
in japanese like here's a no
like shokai like here's an intro to
notion video and i'm trying to get
people hooked into it yeah once you get
into databases and like relations and
roll-ups and then like find your own
like
use case that really clicks and like is
so customized to your experience it's
it's basically like building an app for
yourself it really is yeah especially
they have like an api now i think that i
haven't played with yet but it's just
like you can do everything and anything
with it yeah yeah so actually my like
task notion database is like hooked up
with my google calendar
so like this
talking session
has been added to like my tasks
oh no
it shows up automatically that's kind of
fun
i need to learn how to do that do you
have a video on that because i don't
yeah but it's just on zapier
oh okay yeah yeah yeah yeah that's like
the thing that integrates two things
yes all right let's talk a little bit
about bts too because i
i feel like this is like every time we
talk it's like a yuka-san's like bts
corner
i have to like sprinkle in some bts
content yes yes yes because i i think
like we've talked before about like why
you like bts and it has a lot to do with
like asian american representation and
stuff but like update me with like like
tell me more i guess i don't even know
where like what questions to ask so i'm
just like what
bts i know probably a lot of the viewers
here and listeners are gonna know a lot
more i hope so
i think you're some of your listeners
are also
army
pro yeah oh yeah yeah it's like they're
like everywhere and i feel like it's
like it's so fascinating to see because
for every other asian related
media that's ever been out there it
becomes this like it's it's like i don't
know for anime it's kind of like
like this is gonna sound bad but i'm
just like i kind of can tell if you
watch anime or not
because it's like kind of got that like
otaku vibe sort of a lot of people these
days like anybody watches anime because
it's more available and there's
different kinds and stuff but like bts
truly some i'm like i can't tell who
listens and who doesn't
yeah it's so mainstream right like yeah
can you tell based on their vibe if they
might listen to bts or not
uh sometimes like there is a specific
type of like
clothing
i don't even know what they're called
like like a style that like a style
that i might be like hmm
and also i just like look at people if
i'm if i go to like a bts event or like
uh
uh like i went to a dance class the
other day
i saw that on instagram
that sounds so fun it's so fun being an
army in new york because there's like so
many things happening all the time
there's like flash mobs and dance houses
and cup sleeve events which is like a
cat like a cafe event thing where you
get like cup sleeves
that's yeah
so yeah
um but yeah there's like
so many things going on like every week
so it's really fun
man do you make friends when you go to
those events
sometimes yeah like one time i was uh
you know when it's like somebody's
birthday like bts or any other like kpop
group oh yeah they do like a fan funded
uh
advertisement on like a billboard
at uh times square sometimes wow that's
just power it's so much there's they
have so much power i went to go see it
one time and i was just standing there
and it was so cold by myself and then i
saw somebody with a
bt21
is like you know those the characters
yeah yeah yeah from line
that's like uh bts designed those
characters but um i saw a girl that had
like a little
thing a keychain on her back and she was
like also like staring up at the
advertisement waiting for it to play so
i was like hey like are you army
and then we like ended up talking and uh
like exchanging twitter
and oh
that's so nice
new york is probably like one of the
main central hubs for bts rv maybe other
than los angeles right maybe l.a but
yeah yeah
wow that's so fun like i feel like being
part of like a fan group like that can
be so cool like um i'm not really i
don't i think the only thing that i'm
like a huge huge fan of is snoopy stuff
oh so like if i go to a store i'm really
good at finding snoopy gear
and i have like a couple of friends like
my sister-in-law's also super into
snoopy so anytime there's like a snoopy
collab at a store we send each other
links to like stuff that's cute i don't
know snoopy's kind of everywhere and
it's like kind of old school so there's
not like snoopy events and whatnot
um but i've always admired those
communities like when i was in so um in
san diego comic-con happens like every
year right and it's like one of the
biggest conventions
and so when i was uh before i moved up
to the bay area we my husband and i used
to go to comic-con
not to go to comic-con but to observe
the people going to come
like we would just go to downtown san
diego uh because it's at the convention
center and we like go to bars and stuff
and everyone's so nice because they're
all within their communities
you know and people are like cosplaying
and then eventually we started watching
like doctor who and stuff and so we like
were able to point out doctor who
cosplay
and it was just like the energy is just
so different right and i imagine that's
the same for bts of just like just being
with your people yeah like people who
are also huge fans of stuff is like so
fun yeah and like you
even if you're
like meeting someone for the first time
you at least have one thing to talk
about that yeah
so it's like maybe easier to make
friends or like it's less awkward
totally like go up to people you can
talk about so like so much you could
just talk about only that too yeah
oh how fun well we're coming to the end
of the show uh we talked a little bit a
little bit about creativity freelance
stuff as well as bts but do you always
want to leave off with kind of just like
advice for listeners to kind of just
like and viewers to just
like keep in their minds and stuff so i
think because we talked about creativity
and also kind of crafting your own life
um for anybody who's looking to do that
what advice do you have for folks like
what um
if there could be like a yukasam fortune
cookie
for people we talked in the last episode
where i called a little fortune cookie
but that's so cute yeah what kind of
what advice or words of wisdom would you
share with them
i would say
fine find the yarns within your life to
knit your perfect sweater oh that's so
poetic
i love that
so like
it could be anything from your childhood
or like what you love what you're really
good at um just like blend those
together and make like try to make
something new and
you might create some magic
wow i love that make your own tapestry
yeah by using what you have your
experiences
that's beautiful i love that
knitting has been a theme for today
yeah
amazing well thank you so much for being
on the show today thank you so much for
having me yeah this is so fun i feel
like we got to talk about a lot of stuff
we i feel like whenever we talk we can
talk for hours about any particular
topic so so glad you could finally be on
the show i'm going to leave links to
yuka-san stuff in the description box or
the show notes whichever format you're
watching thanks everybody bye
you can listen to this episode of muku's
corner as a podcast by looking it up in
your favorite podcasting app
[Music]